this is the road to Des Ginja in Moldova
one of the poorest countries in Europe
about 5,000 people live in the village
from the ethnic Agha's minority the
mayor shows us around and points out one
of the biggest improvements to reach the
village in recent years a private aid
organization from Germany donated new
windows for the daycare center at a cost
of 8,500 euros the village has very
little tax revenue many people have
moved away those who stayed are
dependent on donations that's what some
long sumida we have many fields people
could invest here in agriculture in
cultivating the land and raising animals
but I don't know if anyone wants to
invest in that look at our roads our
infrastructure is really very poor super
secluded the Warner slaton the goggles
are very poor on average they earn 100
euros a month most families work very
small farms and most of them aren't even
equipped with machinery everything is
done by hand the mayor's relatives grow
sunflowers and barley like most others
there against EU membership they're
skeptical about the benefits what
matters we've always worked the soil
here together shoulder to shoulder with
the strength of our own bodies we only
trust each other we don't trust anyone
else and we don't need any help from
outsiders we want to remain independent
the goggles are fairly isolated they get
most of their news from Russian language
media outlets in Moscow nothing has
changed economically and politically in
the past 25 years gagauzia is like a
microcosm of the former Soviet Union
private companies are rare they suffer
from high taxes and corrupt civil
servants this factory makes furniture
the workers have no interest in the
European Union they're afraid they'll
lose their jobs
reinke sweta good IE you only thinks of
us as a market for their product
solicitors and on the other hand our
products are not competitive if we join
the EU will go broke we're [ __ ]
ichiban karate the EU still needs to do
a lot of PR work in gagauzia if it wants
to get the people on board no one here
is even aware of its generous farming
subsidies and infrastructure projects
but for them Russell's is a long way
away